("0330hrs Pole Dance")
- I have the weirdest boner right now.
- So anyway, I just have to
eat 12 more boxes of cereal
and then I get a puffin.
- You know that's three minutes of my life
I just won't get back.
- I make $90 an hour working from home.
- (laughs) Same!
- [Group] First, first first
first first, first, first!
- That's when I knew,
I'd never really fall in love.
- Ugh, who cares?
- Hey, did you see that article I posted
on your Facebook wall?
- TLDR.
- Wait, what?
- Too long, didn't read!
- Same.
- Hey, did you get my text about
setting up the cable box?
- [Voiceover] Instructions unclear!
My dick is caught in the ceiling fan!
- I totally ship you guys.
OTP.
- I haven't read the
book, so I'm asking you,
please do not spoil anything.
- Irregardless, I'm over it, dude.
- Irregardless isn't a (bleep) word.
- Yeah, it is.
- No, it's not!
You're a moron.
- Oh my God, that's slay.
("0330hrs Pole Dance")
- Same.